Think about being in a room at night with a lamp on your desk. You drop your
pencil under the desk. The only reason you can see the pencil is that light
from your desk lamp bounces off the walls, ceilings, and other surfaces. Some
of this light makes it to beneath your desk and then gets to your eye. One
reason we don't use lights that drop off at the square of the distance is that
light doesn't bounce around in our scenes, but only effects what it directly
hits. Since there's no light bouncing around it dies off very quickly within
our simplified system. We compensate for this lack of reflected light, called
indirect illumination, by adding a fudge factor called ambient lighting. In 3JS
we set this light by giving it a color. The light color is multiplied by the
material's ambient color to give a solid amount of fill color. Remember that
the ambient color on the material is actually a separate color in 3JS. If you
don't set it, the color is white and the ambient light will simply add some
grey to the object as a whole. Grey's okay but it's better if you set the
ambient color to match the diffuse color. You can then use the ambient light's
intensity to change the feel of the scene as a whole.